with the previous video necromancy
peeking interest surrounding the
different kinds of magic and how they
appear in both classical and modern
storytelling it seems only fitting to
devote a series to the exploration of
magic and its many practices today's
episode will focus on the art of
divination the ability to gain insight
into future events through various
different means and practices those who
did watch the previous video on
necromancy might be thinking this sounds
quite similar to necromancy and that's
because there is some crossover in terms
of being able to obtain information
about the future when Eckerman see only
really achieves us through communing
with the spirits of those already past
divination is a far more extensive
practice of magic in this video we'll be
examining the different aspects of
divination how it featured in past works
of fiction and how it still features
today before we delve any deeper
just like necromancy we should first
establish what divination is and the
reasons for it being practiced in the
first place
when we say divination we essentially
mean the act of seeking knowledge about
the future and the unknown through
supernatural means as for the reasons
why divination is practiced I think the
majority are quite self explanatory
being able to obtain knowledge and
information that is usually not
available is quite a useful talent to
possess some may just want the
comforting feeling that comes with the
knowing what lies ahead and some may
actively seek to change their future
the most common type of divination comes
from interpreting different omens and
signs sometimes these can be quite good
and then again they can also be quite
bad I'm sure many of us remember the
divination scene in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban in this particular
scene professor Trelawney is teaching
the students the art of Tessa Muncie
which in the Harry Potter universe is
essentially the art of reading tea
leaves to predict the future the leaves
in Harry's cup perform a spectral dog
known as the Grimm a symbol of death and
an all-round bad omen now in the books
Harry's cup has more than just one
symbol along with the Grimm we see a
skull meaning there is danger in one's
path a falcon which represents a deadly
foe and a club which predicts an attack
these symbols do foreshadow future
events that take place in the story but
they are all fairly vague and we as an
audience are left to put the pieces
together and essentially predict the
future now the term testament see may
only really exists inside the realms of
the Harry Potter Wizarding World but the
practice of reading tea leaves and
grounds of coffee has existed as a form
of divination for centuries and is often
referred to as Tassie omen C or Tassie
ography Tassie omen C only really began
gaining popularity in the 17 and 1800's
and how far back it goes is quite hard
to say but if we consider the fact that
tea itself was discovered thousands of
years ago then it's safe to say that
it's a fairly old practice most
historians seem to agree that it's an
art that originated from ancient China
as it isn't something we really saw in
Western cultures until Dutch merchants
had established a trade route with China
around the 17th century before then we
did see similar practices in medieval
Europe but often it involved the
mountain of wax and LED or any other
molten substance that would form
unpredictable patterns that could then
be studied the process of reading tea
leaves simply involves pouring a cup of
unstrained tea the cup would then be
shaken well and once the individual was
done drinking the tea any remaining
liquid will be drained and
pattern left behind would be examined
the diviner then interprets the patterns
and links them to symbols that have
meaning behind them for example if the
leaves form something similar to a
clover that would mean good luck
happiness and prosperity is what awaits
you in the future
whereas a snake would be seen as a bad
omen and something like a mountain would
imply a long journey ahead of you there
are tons of different symbols man
normally the fortune teller or the
diviner would group them all together to
create some kind of a prediction some of
you myself included may have seen
something similar but instead using
grounds of coffee and this is something
that is quite common in Greece Serbia
Turkey and various other countries in
the Middle East
similar to reading tea leaves another
very popular type of divination comes in
the form of Tarot now not all decks of
tarot cards were designed for the
purpose of divination in 15th century
Europe they were simply used as playing
cards and again it wasn't until the 18th
century that tarot cards were really
used as a form of divination known as
cartomancy the art of reading counts
Attell one's fortune cartomancy had
existed since the 14th century which was
around the same time playing cards were
first introduced into Europe
much like Tarot each card in the deck
had a specific value and meaning but
this entire process was streamlined when
specific tarot decks were made for
occult purposes such as divination and
more specifically fortune-telling they
presented a much more visual experience
drawing a seven of Spades and being told
what it meant is slightly different than
seen tarot cards such as the hanged man
the lovers or the fall it just has a
more supernatural feel and I guess that
means people are more likely to believe
what the cards represent grown up around
this sort of stuff I never really had a
problem with any of it
I never believed it was real and I still
don't today but I didn't see the problem
of reading tea leaves or tarot cards or
even having your palm read if it's done
for entertainment or self understanding
and reflection however there will be
certain people attracted to this type of
divination that may be in a vulnerable
position
they may have lost loved ones are gone
through some kind of trauma and rather
than seeking the help they need they
turn to things such as tarot cards and
palm reading for this false sense of
comfort or clarity and as with all
things in life where these vulnerable
people exist there will always be those
who attempt to take advantage of them
now this isn't me saying everyone who
reads fortunes or practices divination
is a con artist I know people who do it
for free and people who do it for fun
but it's worth being vigilant of
yourself and the people around you when
it comes to people telling you they can
predict your future for a small fee of
course it's also worth mentioning that
many tarot readers never make the claim
they can predict your future the cards
are more of a guideline and the reader
is simply interpreting a possible
outcome there are countless forms of
divination that each could honestly have
entire videos devoted to them so here's
a quick list of the most popular that I
haven't mentioned osteo man see the
reading of messages found in decaying
bones scrying the art of looking into
reflective surfaces such as water or a
crystal ball in the hopes of detecting
messages numerology the interpretation
of numbers and dates as well as the
value and significance of letters and
lastly rune casting which many of you
may have guessed from the name involves
throwing runes and interpreting the
position they land in this was used by
both the Celtic and Norse people now I
say lastly only because I lost count of
how many subcategories of divination
actually exist but feel free to google
methods of divination and count for
yourself divination as a whole has
appeared all across the world from
medieval Europe to ancient China and
Western Africa it was also a fairly
large part of Mesoamerica and it's
religion there are numerous deities
associated with the practice of magic
and sorcery
Tezcatlipoca was regarded as the patron
of sorcery and a central deity in Aztec
religion divination was practiced in the
everyday life of the Aztec people
through screen surfaces and through the
use of hallucinogenic plants such as
Morning Glory and peyote vision
were created that they believe to
reflect the future now on to Greek
mythology where we see divination quite
often we have gods and goddesses such as
Asteria Caius Apollo and many more that
are associated of prophecy when we think
of divination or prophecy within Greek
mythology it's natural to think of the
Oracles as the primary conduits of the
gods and their prophecies but in reality
this is something we see mostly from
seers who unlike the Oracles had no
direct contact of the gods or divine
gift instead they interpreted certain
science and symbols
mostly through the use of hepatoma sea
or ecstasy the reading of an animal's
entrails which is also another very
popular form of divination and one that
we still commonly see I'm sure most of
you have read a story or watched a TV
show or a movie where a character has
used the entrails of an animal to
perform some kind of ritual or spell
that allows them to predict the future
despite the Oracles appearing in some of
the most well-known Greek stories they
were actually quite rare unlike the
seers which were much easier to contact
this abundance of seers meant they
became quite valuable to the Greek
people
so if seers didn't have the impossible
schedule of an Oracle and they could
both predict the future then why have
Oracle's in the first place it's true
that both Oracle's and seers can predict
the future but seers are far more
limited because they have no connection
to the supernatural if you ask you see
whether you will die tomorrow it will
most likely result in a simple yes or no
answer but an Oracle can tell you that
at midnight a man on a flying horse is
going to drop a boulder on your head
because seers have no connection to the
gods or divine gift they have to rely on
interpreting different signs which means
they can only really give a yes or no
answer but this couple of the fact that
they were often depicted as extremely
wise individuals means they can make you
pretty well-informed guess as to what
your future may be the Oracles
divination came from visions and
messages from the gods meaning they
could provide a more detailed image of
the future now this isn't to say that
one is better than the other they're
just not used in the same way
Sears may not provide a definitive
answer but they are readily available to
most people
whereas Oracle's as gifted as they are
were more so reserved for heroes or
figures of greater importance of stature
so where do we see divination in works
of fiction while going by what we've
discussed so far it's pretty much from
everywhere any story you've read or
movie you've watched that features some
kind of prophecy is an example of
divination being used that prophecy
would have come from some kind of Oracle
or prophet like figure and they would
obtain the information through various
forms of divination now the whole
prophecy trope is something we see all
the time and you could argue it's
overused in cliche but what it does do
is provide an outline of a story or a
key event in that story without really
given away too many details and
spoon-feed in the reader a prophecy can
be self-fulfilling or it can always
change if we look at Greek myth as an
example we have uranus prophesized in
that Cronus will be overthrown by his
children which ultimately results in him
swallowing his own children and lead
into a rebellion against him
contributing to his own downfall and
then you have Metis who makes the same
prediction about Zeus but despite this
prophecy Zeus doesn't really change the
way he behaves and he's still pretty
much an overall dick to everybody when
that day does eventually come when Zeus
his children and the other gods staged a
coup there are far less individuals
involved and the coup is ultimately a
failure making it so that this specific
prophecy does not come true some more
popular examples that are a little bit
more modern include anakin skywalker
who's prophesized to destroy the Sith
and bring balance to the force but of
course he ends up joining them instead
only to eventually turn on them anyway
you have neo from the matrix who's
prophesized as the hero who would
destroy the machines and save all of
humanity but we soon learn that this
prophecy is fake and he's merely meant
to reboot the matrix though in the end
neo does kind of save everyone but it's
at the cost of his own life
and not in the way we first expected
very similar to Anakin
in Harry Potter we have the prophecy
that states that Harry and Voldemort
cannot coexist one will have to kill the
other
Voldemort assumes killing Harry will end
this prophecy but in the end all it does
is make him vulnerable and eventually
leads the prophecy being fulfilled but
as the opposite of what Voldemort
expected just from these few examples we
can see a pattern in how prophecy is
used most prophecies in fiction never
mean what the characters first think
they mean they act as somewhat of a
diversion taking you down one path for
you to later realize it's the wrong path
classic misdirection
now as for characters capable of
divination in storytelling that is
something we see presented in a far
different manner a lot of this comes
down to the very simple fact that being
able to see into the future is extremely
powerful and if it's not implemented
correctly it can ruin a story and an
audience's connection to a character if
you have a character that can use
definition whenever they please and see
as far forward as they want you then
have this problem of them never really
been in any real danger nothing that
happens really matters because
everything can be overcome and avoided
the way most writers combat this is by
limiting the use of divination and quite
often magic in general when you think of
characters who have visions they're
quite often short and distorted the
character roughly knows where they are
and what's happening but the details are
often left out and that's why we
commonly see this kind of divination
occurring during dreams or nightmares
the character and audience have an idea
of what's coming but not enough to
easily prevent what they've seen
divination is a form of magic that has
been practiced for thousands of years if
not more
it's appeared in some of our oldest
recorded stories and continues to be a
staple of modern storytelling is
divination a school of magic that you
knew existed and is it a school of magic
that you believe in let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained